this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 15 with Echo Charles and me Jocko
willink good evening Echo good evening
so I'm in task unit Bruiser and I am the
commander of task unit Bruiser which is
a sounds like a real arrogant thing to
say but I was the guy that was in charge
and we deployed we did a workup we
deployed we came back
when it came back
Leaf so there's two platoon Commanders
Leif and Seth Leaf when we got back
he went to the junior officer training
course and he started running that I
moved into the training Detachment and
started running the training for seals
getting ready to for the seal platoons
and task units getting ready to deploy
to Iraq and Afghanistan and then Seth
actually stepped up
and took my job as task unit Commander
and so he took over tasking to Bruiser
in a way but actually in a way he didn't
because
because they they they split up task
unit Bruiser when we got back
they they took all those as many guys as
they could and they just spread them
into other task units because it was
just too
it was just too much it was too much
like
Force
to have all these guys so you know
Seth kept some of the guys but it was
mostly new guys so that they didn't even
really call themselves tasking a Bruiser
there's a maybe a little semblance left
over but Seth took my job so in the SEAL
Teams we have this thing
I don't want to make it like it's that
big of a thing but we had this thing
called a
we call it the Ouija board is what we
called it and what it is is it's a it's
basically a magnet board
and there's one at the whole command and
the whole command they have on this
magnet Board of everyone that's at the
command they have a little magnet that
has your picture on it your name your
rank and maybe what qualifications you
have and there's one of those in the
Master Chief's office that's you know
huge like a big Blackboard in school
with whatever 200 people on it but then
in a task unit you'll have one too and
so we had one in the task unit we had
the Ouija board
and well when I was the task new
Commander when we got home I I was the
top of the I was the top of the Ouija
board
and then when Seth
stepped up and became the task unit
Commander well he moved up to the top
and but he didn't take me off what he
did with me was he kind of slid my
picture over to the right he was
actually put it above him and then he
put a little he put like a little
cartoon
I think they call a little cartoon call
out so it looked like I was saying so
there was words coming out of my mouth
just had me giving him some simple
instruction and that simple instruction
was
don't [ __ ] it up
and it was something that I had said to
him you know he was he was going out
while he was working for me when I was
the tasking Commander he was working for
me and he was going out we were doing
some training and he had
like a a smaller mission to go out on
pretty early on and it was something
that was it was like going to be a
challenge but it was pretty simple and
pretty straightforward and he looked
like he was you know maybe could use a
little confidence boost
and I was like dude this is no Factor
you got this
and then he he kind of like had you know
in a split second had a little
overconfident look in his face
and so I said don't [ __ ] it up
and you brought him back down and he
went dead you know we laughed about it
but it's true
it's actually it's actually true and it
was true on the Ouija board and he knew
that it was true on the Ouija board and
he the Ouija board is lit is literally
sitting in front of his desk so when he
would look up from his desk he sees the
Ouija board he sees all of his troops
and he sees me and and that little call
out saying don't [ __ ] it up and he knew
it was the truth
because it's the best job in the world
best job in the world
being in a seal platoon or being in a
sealed task unit and being in a
leadership role is an honor to be in
that situation you got all these you got
all these guys that are actually
relying on you to do a good job
and make the right decisions and to not
[ __ ] it up
and he didn't he didn't
he did a great job as a task unit
commander and when he went overseas
another interesting thing was you know
he was pretty
the the the
deployment to ramadi was freaking hard
and he did I don't know how many
operations but it was a [ __ ] ton
and
you know had a bunch of guys wounded
right before we came home you know he
had he had Mikey killed
and it was rough
and so when he was getting ready to when
we got back he wasn't quite sure what he
was going to do and I said listen man do
the task unit Commander I go that things
are chilling out you'll go over there
it's not going to be a big deal I'm in
charge of training it'll be fun
and you know once you get overseas you
know it'll just be no Factor there's not
the the war is going to be settled down
it's a year and a half away
well sure enough he gets over there
expecting to have this mellow deployment
and
um when some of the army leadership
found out that there was guys from task
unit Bruiser back in country they sent
out
a request for forces but it was very
specific it was like we would like to
have approximately this many seals with
this kind of experience and they might
as well have said you know six foot one
blonde hair shaved head blue eyed
commander of that unit like wanting
stoner
so that's what happened and they they
put together a crew and went into
executed a bunch of uh operations in
solder City and Baghdad that were that
was they were extremely effective
operations and the Insurgent leadership
inside solder City solder City had been
a total disaster for the entire war that
was 2008 so for five straight years
solder City had been
really horrible and
his task unit rolled in there and and
they killed a lot of bad guys and the
Insurgent leaders I think it was about
six weeks of operations that they did
they killed hundreds of bad guys and
then the Insurgent leadership in there
surrendered they basically surrendered
all right we're good
so that was it so then he finished that
eventually came home and you know he
continued on with his career I retired
and and
fast forward a few years
actually you fast forward from 2008 to
2017 so almost a decade
and Seth got killed in a in a parachute
accident
and
and so I no longer
you know have uh the ability to offer
him any advice or anything like that and
I don't have the opportunity to tell him
to not [ __ ] things up
but
it's it's interesting because I was
thinking about this the other day and
it's like the roles have been reversed
and now
I think probably Seth is looking down on
me
and
he sees me he sees my life he sees the
freedom that that I have that we have
the opportunity that we all have
the opportunity to do more and and make
ourselves better and help more people
and and have an impact on the world and
I can I can imagine and I do imagine
that he's sitting there looking down on
me
and he's saying the same thing
he's telling me the same thing that I
told him
which is don't [ __ ] it up
and why am I saying this why am I why am
I why am I reciting this story
um
it's because it's actually really good
advice
it's actually really good advice for us
all to take it's it's simple it's
straightforward and it actually makes
sense when you are making decisions if
you think through what you're doing
and you overlay the simple principle
of not [ __ ] it up you'll see that
life's filled with all kinds of
opportunities and chances and things are
going to get hard and there's going to
be challenges of course but there's
people out there and there's experiences
you can have and they're all sitting
right there in front of you
so don't [ __ ] it up
straightforward advice right thinks oh
yeah
it's similar advice uh I've I've given
other I think I think this was JP
it was I don't know if I gave it to JP
or I was we were talking about someone
else but it was uh
don't do dumb [ __ ] like this is another
great piece of advice because how many
people do you know have sent their lives
into a freaking downward spiral because
they're doing dumb [ __ ]
if you can just not do dumb [ __ ] and
don't [ __ ] it up you're gonna be on a
pretty good path
yeah I wonder why that is that why
people do dumb [ __ ] no like the
difference between doing dumb [ __ ] just
if you're not told
versus one you are told it's kind of
like oh wait I'm not supposed to do dumb
[ __ ] and then you kind of won't in a way
like if you if you keep it in mind you
know even though it seems pretty obvious
like what do you call like doesn't need
to be said or whatever but it kind of
helps is that if it gives you that one
more millisecond filter on your decision
making process to say you know what this
is some dumb [ __ ] right now yeah
but it's almost like it makes it
official you know like hey you you just
literally broke the rule right now it's
like oh man I broke that rule but if you
don't say it it's like well that's not
really a rule and you can justify the
guy was saying the wrong thing he
stepped on my foot whatever you know
elicits the dumb [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] but if
it's a rule it's almost like a little
psychological thing
yeah um language-wise you know we we
early on we had like a podcast about
like not swearing and um you know I was
basically saying hey you know it's
doesn't really in many cases doesn't
help your message especially you're
talking to a broad audience you know
who's listening et cetera et cetera I
got recordings of me debriefing
seals and it's just F-bomb it's F carpet
bombing it's carpet bombing there's one
every three sentences I I sent it out to
the the dudes from Echelon front I sent
like a little clip out I was just F-bomb
F-bomb then the interesting thing is I'm
talking about I'm talking about the
exact same things that I talk about all
the time right now the first one I sent
them was me talking about cover and move
and I you know I'm sitting there saying
and I'm talking to a seal task unit
that's going through some training
and I'm saying you guys heard me [ __ ]
say cover Move you [ __ ] heard me say
that [ __ ] there's a [ __ ] reason why I
say that [ __ ] the [ __ ] reason I say
that is because if you're out there in
the [ __ ]
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you
to assistance at Jocko underground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then we will see you mobilized
Underground